das tags präsident meine damen und
herren wir werden heute wieder viel
einigkeit erleben
es ist doch schön nicht wahr wenn man an
gemeinsamen feind hat und sich auch
einig ist wo man ihn suchen muss nämlich
rechtsextremismus aber entwickelt sich
an allen rändern rechts ebenso wie links
im internet twitter ganz offenen
erscheinung
er zeigt sich auf der inzwischen
verbotenen linksextremen plattform links
unten in die media auf der regelmäßig
zur gewalt gegen andersdenkende
aufgerufen wurde oder auch bei linken
strategietreffen wo darüber fabuliert
wird ein prozent der reichen zu
erschießen oder ins arbeitslager zu
schicken
es zeigt sich im rassismus von einem
sich hartnäckig halten den linken
antisemitismus extremismus kommt aber
niemals nur von einer seite meine damen
und herren sondern immer von links wie
von rechts
wenn extremistische tendenzen einer
gesellschaft erstarken dann läuft für
alle erkennbar etwas grundsätzlich
schief dann muss ich vor allem die
politik fragen was sie falsch gemacht
hat dann ist es höchste zeit die
ursachen für diese fehlentwicklungen und
die verantwortlichen zu benennen aber
nichts davon ist in den letzten jahren
geschehen
ich habe nicht ein einziges mal einen
politiker aus ihren reihen gehört der
ernsthaft ein nachdenken über die
entwicklung eingefordert hat die unser
land nimmt meine damen und herren
gehen sie ins land hinaus und schauen
sie sich um
deutschland ist tief gespalten zum einen
geografisch die kluft zwischen ost und
west wächst weiter zum anderen sozialen
die schere zwischen arm und reich geht
weiter auseinander
und drittens erlebt dieses land eine
politisch-moralische spaltung in die
guten und die bösen und genau diese
moralisierung des politisch
brandgefährlich meine damen und herren
sie selbst haben sie geschaffen indem
sie den politischen diskurs auf die
moralische ebene verlagerten
dorthin wo er sachargumenten eine
vernunft basierten debatte nicht mehr
zugänglich ist und wer das kritisiert
gehört bereits zu den bösen und wird
ausgegrenzt wenn sie all den menschen
die ihre meinung nicht teilen ständig
den mund verbieten wenn sie diese leute
stigmatisieren und gesellschaftlich
isolieren dann schaffen sie selbst die
räume der radikalisierung mit ihrer
politik haben sie die axt an die
meinungsfreiheit und damit an die
lebensader die demokratie gesetzt
inzwischen fürchten 60 prozent der
deutschen die in der öffentlichkeit
nicht mehr zu allen themen frei äußern
zu können
ihre politik meine damen und herren hat
ein klima der angst geschaffen
und jetzt kommen wir als afd und halten
ihnen den spiegel vor
was sie sehen ist hässlich das will ich
ihnen gerne glauben aber sie müssen doch
selbst einmal darüber nachdenken was ihr
vorgehen für den gesellschaftlichen
klima zu tun hat in dem der mord an
walter lübke und die schrecklichen
anschlägen hahne und hatte überhaupt
möglich wurden
wenn in frankfurt ein kind vor einen zug
gestoßen wird dann geht man schnell zum
tagesgeschehen über der täter sei
psychisch krank gewesen heißt es dann
wenn in hanau ein psychisch kranker
menschen erschießt wird daraus rechter
terrorismus rast an tage später wieder
mein fahrzeug absichtlich in eine
menschenmenge geht das im grund brauchen
der täglichen berichterstattung unter
man erfährt wenig über die hintergründe
die opfer und den täter jedes dieser
ereignisse hätte nicht geschehen dürfen
aber die einen signieren und die anderen
politisch zu instrumentalisieren das
treibt die spaltung unserer gesellschaft
voran
erst vor wenigen tagen mit unser
parteivorsitzender tino club nada vor
einem weiteren aufheizen der politischen
klima gewarnt prompt wurden er und seine
familie opfer eines brandanschlages von
den gesundheitlichen schäden ist er bis
heute nicht genesen auch dieses tat war
das werk von extremisten und sie zeigt
uns einmal mehr dass es nicht damit
getan ist extremismus allein auf der
rechten seite zu suchen sondern ist es
nur einer gemeinsamen kraftanstrengung
aller demokratischen kräfte gelingen
wird die gesellschaftlichen
rückzugsräume zu extremisten wieder zu
schließen von rechts wie von links darin
soweit roland tat sich von der afg